1 reflection on the lie
yesterday or the day before yesterday I was listening to Mr.
Feijo
to say that politicians should not lie
and I found it curious.
First,
because I did it in en
in the third person singular no,
and did not talk about himself.
And that is 1 lapse
of these typical ones that the fixed gentleman has,
especially in the campaign,
right?
But notice 1 thing about the lie,
the fixed gentleman only had 1 speech,
only 1 and turned out to be 1 Big lie.
And I ask you,
and I also ask the Galicians,
which fixed should be kept?
What,
which fixed is the real
the one who negotiated pardons and amnesty with the
independentistas
or the one who wanted to outlaw the parties
independentistas?
Well, you know,
I am going to give you the answer,
none,
because the only truth of Faith,
son,
is that everything about him is a lie,
1 Big lie